>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
THE DRUG COMPANY FIRED THIS
MORNING ANNOUNCE -- PFIZER THIS
MORNING ANNOUNCED IT IS ASK THE
FDA FOR FULL APPROVAL FOR USE OF
THE COVID VACCINE.
IT IS CURRENTLY FOR EMERGENCY
USE ONLY.
ALSO THIS MORNING, THERE'S A
BRAND-NEW INITIATIVE TO TRACK
THE CORONAVIRUS VARIANTS THAT
COULD THREATEN OUR RECOVERY.
IT INVOLVES A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN FORMER BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER TONY BLAIR'S INSTITUTE
FOR GLOBAL CHANGE.
SCIENTISTS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF OXFORD AND OUR OWN DR. DAVID
AGUS, THROUGH HIS ELLISON
INSTITUTE FOR TRANSFORMATIVE
MEDICINE.
THIS IS JUST THE FIRST OF MANY
PROJECTS FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
WHICH THEY'RE CALLING THE GLOBAL
HEALTH SECURITY CONSORTIUM.
AND OUR DR. DAVID AGUS JOINS US
NOW AT THE TABLE.
HE'S IN MY CHAIR BECAUSE OF
COVID PROTOCOLS.
>> YES.
>> HAVING A LITTLE DISTANCE
HERE.
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO WELCOME YOU.
>> A MILESTONE.
IN THE SAME ROOM.
>> YEAH.
>> I KNOW.
>> BUT THIS IS WHAT GETS ME --
WE'VE ALL BEEN VACCINATED.
BUT WE STILL CAN'T ALL BE
TOGETHER.
>> THESE ARE THE CDCRULES,
RIGHT?
THE.
>> NO.
THESE ARE THE CBS RULES.
NOT NECESSARILY THE CDC RULES.
FOUR PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATE
TODAY GET TOGETHER --
>> YOU'RE MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
CDC --
>> AT LEAS IN THIS BUILDING --
>> WE'VE GOT THE ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION GOING.
>> THIS IS A BIG CHAIR IF YOU
WANT TO SIT DOWN.
>> WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE NEW PARTNERSHIP?
>> IT'S EXCITING TO WORK WITH
THE GROUP AT OXFORD AND PRIME
MINISTER BLAIR TO FOLLOW THE
VARIANTS ACROSS THE GLOBE.
GETTING COUNTRIES TO SHARE DATA
-- HISTORICALLY COUNTRIES SAID I
DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW MY
VARIANT DATA BECAUSE IT'S A
CHECKMARK AGAINST PLEA.
IT SHOWS THAT I'M DOING
SOMETHING WRONG.
NOW IF WE GET THEM TO SLAYER IT,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH THE NEW BOOSTERS FOR THE
VACCINES, AND WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON GLOBALLY WITH RETURN TO
POLICY.
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT.
>> HOW DO YOU TRACK THE
VARIANTS?
>> WE CALL DNA SEQUENCING.
RIGHT NOW YOU GET A PCR TEST
THAT SAYS YES, NO, YOU HAVE THE
VIRUS.
IF WE LOOK AT THE 30,000 LETTERS
OF THE CODE, WE CAN SAY DID IT
CHANGE FROM YESTERDAY, DID IT
CLIMATE CHANGE FROM OTHER PEOPLE
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD?
IF IT'S STARTING TO CHANGE, WE
NEED TO TAKE NOTICE.
AND NOT JUST NOTICE WHEN A
COUNTRY BECOMES LIKE INDIA, KNOW
IN ADVANCE THAT SOMETHING IS
STARTING TO HAPPEN.
>> THAT LEADS TO THE NEXT
QUESTION.
WHAT ABOUT INDIA, ARE YOU
GETTING DATA FROM, THERE AND CAN
YOU TRACK THE VARIANTS?
>> THE VARIANTS IN INDIA
OBVIOUSLY ARE MUCH MORE
INFECTIOUS.
WE SAW IT EXPLODEIN INDIA.
THE NUMBER OF CASES EVERY DAY
ARE BREAKING RECORDS.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT ELSE
IS HAPPENING IN INDIA YET
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BEING
TOTALLY TRANSPARENT WITH THEIR
DATA.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON.
WITH ALL THOSE NUMBERS OF CASES
AND THE VIRUS REPLICATING OR
DIVIDING IN EVERY PATIENT, MORE
VARIANTS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE KEY NOW IS TRYING TO KNOW IN
ADVANCE.
>> HOW WORRIED --
>> HOW WORRIED SHOULD WE BE
ABOUT INDIA?
>> THE REASON I WAS GOING TO ASK
THE SAME THING, WHEN IT FIRST
HAPPENED WITH CORONAVIRUS, IT
WAS IN CHINA.
>> YEAH.
>> WE WERE TOLD IF YOU HAVEN'T
BEEN TO CHINA, IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY WHO'S COME FROM CHINA,
YOU'VE HAD NO ASSOCIATION WITH
CHINA, YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
-- IN THE VERY BEGINNING.
I THINK MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT,
OKAY, I DON'T NEED TO WORRY.
HOW WORRIED SHOULD WE BE THAT
IT'S HAPPENING IN INDIA?
>> UNTIL TUESDAY WE HAVE PLANS
GOING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
HERE AND INDIA.
NOW, IF YOU HAVE A U.S. PASSPORT
YOU CAN STILL TRAVEL FROM INDIA
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
WE SHOULD BE WORRIED.
THE VARIANTS CLEARLY ARE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> THEY ARE HERE?
>> THEY HAVE NOT SPREAD
DRAMATICALLY.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S NEXT.
THE CURRENT VARIANTS, ALL OF
THEM, SOUTH AFRICA, BRAZIL, THE
UNITED KINGDOM, INDIA, OUR
VACCINES WORK.
THAT IS TREMENDOUSLY
ENCOURAGING.
THAT'S A REALLY POSITIVE SIGN.
>> THEN ONE OF THE BIG QUESTIONS
IS HOW DO WE GET THE REST OF THE
WORLD ACCESS TO OUR VACCINES?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SUPPORTING THIS IDEA TO OPEN UP
THE FORMULAS TO MAKE THE DRUG
COMPANIES KIND OF GIVE UP THEIR
PATENT PROTECTION AND ALLOW
GENERICS IN THOSE COUNTRIES.
THE DRUG COMPANIES ARE SAYING
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY GOING TO
HELP, IT'S GOING TO BE A
MANUFACTURING PROBLEM.
WHAT'S THE REALITY?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT,
J&J, ASTRAZENECA, AND PFIZER,
THEY ARE SELLING VACCINES FOR
COST IN DEVELOPING WORLD.
MAKING NO PROFIT.
THEY ARE PRETTY GOOD AT
MANUFACTURING.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST MANUFACTURING
PLANTS HAS STILL NOT HAD ONE
DOSE, AND WE HAD TO THROW OUT 15
MILLION DOSES FROM THE EMERGENT
PLANT IN MARYLAND.
IT IS HARD TO MANUFACTURE THESE.
THAT ADMINISTRATION -- DECISION
ON THE PATENTS, I DON'T THINK
IT'S GOING TO MAKE ANY IMPACT IN
THE SHORT RUN.
WHAT WE NEED IS TO CONTINUE
MANUFACTURING VACCINES AND THEN
TO DISTRIBUTE THEM IN THE RIGHT
PLACES, IN THE RIGHT WAY.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT WE'RE
OPENING UP TOO SOON IN THIS
COUNTRY?
I KNOW WE'RE ALL COVID TIRED.
I GET IT.
MYSELF INCLUDED.
BUT DO YOU WORRY THAT WE'RE
OPENING UP TOO EARLY SINCE SO
MANY PEOPLE STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THE VACCINE?
I WAS IN A CAR THE OTHER DAY AND
CASUALLY ASKED THE DRIVER, HAVE
YOU HAD A VACCINE?
AND HE SAID NO.
IT SORT OF -- I WAS VERY
UNSETTLED BY IT.
>> YEAH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM AND ISRAEL WHERE
CERTAIN AREAS ARE WAY AHEAD OF
US IN VACCINES, IF WE CAN GET
OUR NUMBERS 15% HIGHER,
VACCINATE 15% MORE PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES, OUR VIRUS NUMBERS
WILL FALL ALMOST 15-FOLD.
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO GET TO.
>> I MEAN, WHATEVER THE NEW
NORMAL IS, WHEN DO WE GET THERE?
>> MY HOPE IS WE CAN GET THERE
BY THE BEGINNING OF THE SUMMER.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE VACCINATING.
>> WHAT'S THE BEGINNING OF THE
SUMMER?
>> THE BEGINNING OF THE SUMMER
IS GOING TO BE THE END OF JUNE.
AND I THINK THAT IF WE CAN GET
12 TO 15 WHICH SHOULD BE
APPROVED IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
DAYS, THAT AGE GROUP, THAT'S
ANOTHER 17 MILLION KIDS RIGHT
THERE.
THAT'S GOING TO HELP GET US
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE PUSHING FOR
THE VACCINE.
>> WHAT'S THE PERCENTAGE WE NEED
TO GET TO?
>> I THINK IF WE CAN GET TO THE
LOW 70s WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A
GOOD SPOT.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
BOOSTERS WHICH WILL COME ALONG
IN PROBABLY TOWARD THE END OF
THE YEAR TO KEEP THE IMMUNITY TO
THESE NEW VARIANTS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
BOOSTERS?
>> MOST OF THE POPULATION WILL
HAVE BOOSTERS.
>> DR. DAVID AGUS